all right Skye yes Skye where are you
from originally where'd you grow up Iowa
what part
um like North Springs it's a small
little town
tell me about your family
um
I don't know that's kind of hard to talk
about
um my biological dad
um was a addict
um I didn't meet him for like 27 years
um the guy that adopted me I cried
because I'm sorry is it bad I cry no
everyone cries here okay
um the guy that adopted me is the nicest
guy The Greatest Dad
but um
I've just been [__] up for like years
now and
just breaking his heart
um
my mom died four years ago but
I had a really good childhood
um I have a brother
he's great too
so you were adopted
Yeah by my dad and you stayed with him
until when
um well
what are you gonna say about him you're
living in Los Angeles now yeah because I
I was I came out here for Rehab
once you got into drugs back there
um yeah after my mom died I started
drinking really really heavy
your mom died
four years ago four years ago yeah how
old are you 28 28 yeah
you came out here so you started with
alcohol
um I went down to Florida for four years
um for alcohol
um I got real bad like seizing out and
like hallucinating if I stopped drinking
then I got really heavy into air duster
excited
found out and halfway that is a pop-up
on drug test but I probably shouldn't
say that
um
I just in that cycle I was just with
really abusive people
and so I had to come out here and try to
get help I thought I was going to stay
sober but
I just recently got kicked out of my um
sober living
the air gesture is your current yeah
drug yeah yeah you're not the first one
I've interviewed yeah it's just terrible
you can buy it anyway right yeah
it's legal
um shocking enough I've been in jail for
huffing it so many times because I pass
out and have seizures and stuff on it I
guess that's illegal in California
and what does air duster do for you
um it helps me not feel anything like I
don't feel like non-existent
that's who it's great
yeah I've been drugs and alcohol are I
mean they're not like you have the
normies
and then
people with some trauma
that don't know how to cope and deal
with their feelings so they just numb it
but yeah I mean industrial you do is
pass out
so I don't know why I think it's
it's not great this last time I just
decided I'm done with it
can't do it anymore
what do you think you're trying to
escape from
um
my mom died
she had Ms so I was her caretaker
um she became paralyzed and
it was just really sad to watch and then
she died and I just felt like everything
I just felt really bad for her
um
what was the question
what are you trying to escape from you
know
yeah and I'm sure I try I don't think
abusive relationships affect me but I'm
sure it does like I've never been with a
guy who hasn't punched me in the face
which is not good because I have a great
dad like a great role model so
so there's nothing in your childhood
that kind of
set you up for this kind of these kind
of relationships now that you're grown
I mean I'm sure someone wearing there
with my biological dad leaving that
affects me somehow but like I said I had
a great childhood my dad's great my mom
was great
you're adopted Dad yeah yeah
so you have black eyes now you have a
bunch of scrapes and yeah it's not funny
it's really not this is like a week old
so everything's healing up really nice
but yeah I'm I had I ended up sleeping
over on Slauson in like South Central
and I got robbed and he was punching me
and I fell into the concrete
and took my phone my bags my clothes
what are you doing down there you're
sleeping in a bad neighborhood down
there Slauson I I know I know as close
to the Home Depot where they sell Air
Duster oh dumb
dumb
do you have kids no kids no
where are you staying now
um
well I'm homeless except one night I it
was just really cold out and I had
walked like five miles the wrong
direction where I was going so I was
hitchhiking
and this older gentleman pulled over
and
um he asked me if I needed a place to
stay
and I said yeah and so I've been at his
house kind of for like the past five
days but he's gotten really weird and I
just uncomfortable and
I just need to find somewhere to go
how do you make money now
I don't have any money
maybe like how do you support yourself
um like a habit
like if you're buying Air Duster or food
or I mean it's bad but I steal it you
steal yeah
but I mean
four or five years ago I mean I had an
apartment my car I was working in a
salon
things were good you know I had money in
my pocket
and then everything just kind of like
flipped upside down and
I'm here
is that because of the drug use
yeah yeah but I think drug use
isn't the problem it's like a symptom of
the problem yeah that's what I believe
too yes
there's something deeper
that's making you use the drug yes
you think it's just losing your
the relationship you had with your
biological dad maybe
losing your mom I mean I actually I met
him uh two years ago
and I did not like him at all you know
he was racist he's against gay people
I'm not with all that I think everybody
should be themselves
but besides I'm just really glad that I
was adopted by someone so great and nice
so I don't think it affects me now
does your
biological father know your current
situation
um no
and you're too ashamed to let him know
um yeah
because like
he had like um
stopped talking to me for like four or
five years
because it was just hurting him too bad
and it's really hard to deal with
so I just want him to think that I'm
doing good so
what do you go through mostly
emotionally
um
sometimes I don't feel anything but when
I talk about
my dad or my mom
I get really emotional
I'd even think I would cry honestly but
I just like trying walking around
looking for shelters I'm just like where
did where's my life gone
yeah sorry
what's your would you say is your
biggest regret
um I mean in the past not being nicer to
my mom
but it was just really hard
um dealing with that and having to do
everything for her and feed her and
bathe her and
pure cry all the time and just too much
so I was kind of rude sometimes but um
I mean my biggest regret at this moment
was relapsing and using drugs again
because now I'm over you said this is in
your skid row looking for homeless
shelters that I can't get into
and standing out in the rain
so I'd say this is pretty Rock Bottom
yeah I can send you some places that
might be able to help you
um do you have any friends
I have a friend in Iowa
um she's a good friend
um do I take her advice ever no
um
but yeah she's a she's a good good
person
helpful and thoughtful
why do you think you don't take
her advice
um I tend to do
um
the opposite of what
that's right I don't know like I know
it's right and wrong but I always do the
wrong
I don't know if it's easier or it's just
um
I don't know I don't know where I'm
going with that do you find yourself
sabotaged a lot yeah so Saturday I also
have a borderline personality disorder
so I don't trust my thoughts you know
they're all distorted
where were you diagnosed with borderline
I'm in seventh grade and then a couple
times when I was in treatment I've
always known I had it just like heavy
abandonment issues
feelings of emptiness things like that
what's the most serious your BPD has
gotten I mean how serious is it yeah it
consumes my life
yes I mean are you suicidal sometimes
always really yeah
so it affects your choices of Partners
yeah your decision making I'm sure
I mean and it sucks in therapy though
you can't tell them that you want to die
because then they'll put you in a psych
ward but how are you supposed to like
um
get through it without telling people
so you just kind of keep it to yourself
you know
you feel misunderstood by most people
um
yeah for the most part
it's like
I don't put this
I'm not doing all this because I want to
I mean that sounds stupid
it's like once you start and you're an
addict you cannot stop it sucks
and people don't get that and they don't
believe that
but
it takes people to like the darkest
places and they still can't stop because
it's such a mental Obsession until you
do it it won't go away so
I think addiction is a disease of the
mind anyways
what would you say is your biggest fear
what do you worry about being alone
really
yeah and do you feel alone down here
yes
I mean you're hanging out in some of the
most dangerous neighborhoods well I
called like 20 20 shelters in like
Venice and Los Angeles and I couldn't
get referrals and I didn't have a case
manager
and I couldn't get in anywhere and so
someone I met told me to try out these
places so I'm trying but I don't have an
ID so it's been really hard
if you had your life to live over again
what would you have done differently
huh
probably let's I don't know I don't know
I want to say not do drugs but to be
honest it it's made I don't even know if
I like who I am so I can't say that
if I can do anything over
I would just spend no more time with my
parents
and try to do the right thing more often
do you find your borderline personality
disorder kind of colors everything that
you do
colors at what it affects everything you
do yeah 100 you know what's strange you
could
you can say what it is but um in Canada
they now do assisted suicide with people
that have borderline personality
disorder
really yeah
yeah
you feel hopeless sometimes always 100
percent
yeah I never feel good
I I can like laugh but
I don't know I don't feel good ever I'm
just a really sad person
was there anyone else in your family
that had BPD
um I don't think so
I mean my mom had depression and
everything but
and my brother's a psychologist so
has he helped you at all
um yeah at first he didn't understand
um he was helping veterans for the VA
but now he's working with drug addicts
instead so he's trying to understand
more
you've been alive before
yes
I don't know
I always think I'm in love
but they're always really mean to me
so that's love
do you tend to choose partners that are
eventually abusive
every one of them is abusive I get
really nervous around guys
I don't trust them at all
and is it is it just guys in particular
or is it your choice of guys
um usually it's my choice of guys but
um
now I just get nervous around anybody
that anyone could freak out
rob me beat me up well down here you're
gonna meet Tony I know how many people
do that I know
yeah a woman with black eyes is like a
state bird down here I know and I hate
it everyone keeps staring at me
I'm like oh my God I hope this goes away
soon it was real bad but it's healing
it's healing up nice I can't complain
but
yeah
what are your what are your goals where
would you like to be in five years
I want a baby
to be my best friend
um just be happy
be happy yeah
are there medications or anything you've
taken that have helped you
um yeah usually I'm on medication and
I'm so bad taking medication even though
it helps
so
I haven't been taking it but like I said
I don't know I'm so emotional
but I guess it happens yeah
yeah you think your decision to use
the computer cleaner instead of uh the
medications that might help you
it sounds terrible for you
I don't think people get that but you
you decide to use that instead of the
medications is that part of your BPD
I'm in impulse control for sure but
I don't want to say this but
I mean meds help but I mean drugs and
alcohol create so many more problems but
for the time being they make you feel
nothing and it's great
but there's consequences to your actions
always so
I learned that the hard way
what do you think most of the people out
there don't understand about people that
have a mental disorder like like
borderline like I said I'm not doing
this for fun like I
it's
like
um some people just say like just stop
or
um
my God it's so hard to explain like just
don't do it yeah if you can't just not
do it
yeah it's weird to wrap your head around
that because even when I'm saying out
loud it doesn't make sense but so true
I mean my it's distorted thinking it's
black and white thinking your cognitive
disorders are everywhere like
yeah don't trust your first thought ever
and then you're very misunderstood by
everyone
yes
I used to tell my dad that because I
didn't think he understood it he's
um
he's like why would you destroy your
life
it's like
I didn't know that I was an addict I
really believe people are born
addicts I mean maybe as a child
um you indulged in something too much
you like something too much you're
obsessive you might have had like OCD or
something
and I I mean without
therapy and everything I think that it
can spiral into something darker like
people see homeless people out on the
street
and they just think that they're like
worthless or like they don't have value
in life but
I think a lot of addicts are the nicest
people I've ever met to be honest with
you
yeah a lot of them are very surprisingly
yeah they're just hurting intelligent
and yeah they're just
on a spiral of self-destruction yeah
and it's really hard to bring yourself
back up
when
now you have nothing
I suspect a lot of the people I
interview
who I
describe as just a fentanyl addict or a
crack addict or whatever yeah are
actually
borderline they're probably BPD or
bipolar
yeah a lot of them are yeah there's
always a mental illness behind it yeah
it all wraps around that Mental Health
is important yes it is
yeah it's everything
you've had rough experiences on the
street I assume like like your face is
showing right now
I'm just getting beat up and robbed
taking advantage of
you just get [__] with sorry when
you're a girl and you're homeless you
know
it's scary I hate it it's so scary
you can't really sleep so you do drugs
to keep you up
you know something bad doesn't happen
yeah
it's just a cycle
a destructive cycle
is this the lowest point of your life
right now
Maybe
I mean alcohol really destroyed my life
I had a lot of serious complications
from alcohol
but
maybe yeah I'm sure this is I mean I'm
but what's a more destructive drug for
you or alcohol or the air duster Air
Duster no which is bizarre
I used to not tell people that because
they make fun of me and say it's not a
drug
yes it is
so you'll you'll
Breathe It You'll Huff it yeah I always
get two cans and say they'll be done and
then 10 hours later I've done like 30
cans
seized out peed myself
it's terrible
when you first when did you first start
drinking
um
I've dabbled in high school but heavier
drinking after my mom died I got to like
a gallon a day
uh
what would you say is your greatest
strength
I'm nice you're nice because usually
somebody had might have BPD I I find
they also have some really great
qualities that are
yeah I mean they're kind of like split
personalities like
but my intentions are always pure
I don't think I'm mean to anybody ever
this guy what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
I'm learning my lesson right now but I'm
not I mean
sorry I haven't been to sleep in days
um I saw him kind of all over the place
right now how do you stay awake for days
yes oh you're doing math too mm-hmm
yeah
I hate it because I'm my body's so
exhausted because I've been up for five
days
but I'm wired and then you just start
seeing things that aren't there
sucks
so what would you say is the most
important thing you've learned I'll
support you know
I really don't know I don't know how to
answer that
I mean the simple question would be like
don't do drugs that ruin your life but
I mean drugs also taught me a lot about
myself
and it may be
um
like when you get into AAA it really
teaches you how to be a better person
for others and stop being so selfish and
self-centered
um
I don't know the greatest lesson I've
learned
that's right you're young yeah you're
still young so yeah
but this is a big Learning lesson I'm
sure hopefully in like a month
this all comes to like fluidity and
something good happens do you find that
your BPD will like come in waves
where you're more self-destructive at
times than others
um yeah because I was doing really
really good in sober living
and I like myself sober
but I just don't like how I feel I'm a
good person I just
don't feel right
I mean you don't feel right you'll do
what
was that when you don't feel right
you'll do what the wrong thing I'll get
high yeah
it's just a quick impulsive
one minute it just makes everything go
away
it ruins your life but at least you feel
better
which is bizarre because that makes no
sense either
because do I feel good look at me
but
all right this guy thank you so much for
sharing your story
thank you I'll show you where to get
some housing oh yeah